walk up this video against em kenstar
kenstar Kenneth Solomon can you solo the
days from South Africa i'm not mistaken
check with an italian flag okay um ya
gotta go that last game was really
really costly hmm it's a rare move order
but of course not not bad
your looks like a fairly normal position
for this opening it is as I said a
little bit uncommon what you did down in
the move order just trying to be quick
not spending too much time I cam let's
freeze the queenside a little bit them I
wonder ever should play a form and then
try to support that porn on that central
square e 492 in a night f8 and Bishop f5
this is this kind of thing maybe
hmm yeah it's difficult not to play
before really it's difficult what should
be six let us make some sense actually
look at the sea for porn makes it a
little bit tough of them hmm oh yeah
much choice here probably
champa takes f6 I don't know I take what
the Queenie probably can really just
take your form it's really no reason not
her not to take for him and maybe i have
ninety-seven something-something pinning
Queen takes Knight takes Queen g6 is ok
this is this is really okay Bishop takes
her Evers a problem Bishop takes Knight
takes Queen g6 f3 and then I have no
great move really cool chicks Bishop
Jake's is there anything else takes
Knight X not working jg takes looks damn
ugly and can probably have to do it
I take 1 F 2 Queen chicks takes on g2
yeah not much choice so what happens
here Queen hm sorry rook h4 essa is a
problem and 94 well
okay what the heck what is he doing to
Mia the sky is not such a strong strong
i immune why is he actually a GM now
said the guy there is one know there is
one south african player who now is it
grandmaster by winning i think the
african championships are something like
that maybe that's him he really played
as well need some activity here yeah III
and b2 are still under fire not sure if
I'm really in that bad shape fairly
active
I'm quite sure what he's supposed to do
they cannot really give up b2 and move
like rook f1 i will take be too and now
III hanks and I'm taking this
threatening group d 3 something like
that just being a general annoyance now
that is really not that bad for me rook
to d3 or just taken taking it's not bad
but 95 maybe Luke d3 I would like to
play rook d3 actually but maybe not
maybe that's not that great so here I
Scott c5
not sure maybe that is too ambitious
here let move 93 95 is my idea
preventing c5 and then 95 why do you
maybe now I can do that 92 Luke t3 is
not that much of a problem led to look
you three should be okay nothing else
though okay rook deform then he plays
King III time working no it doesn't whoa
I didn't see that one coming why is he
surprising me all the time that's not
fair
now it's got 95 now no it doesn't do
that okay check not sure about this now
that's it wrong so we do just wrong well
our third can I do anything probably not
wrong wrong probably not just a draw
whoa but he really played a very strong
game there Jack hello it's a bit of a
bit of a strange not strange with the
uncommon water and maybe I didn't play
it play it right yeah he for was was
very tempting fire mission takes yeah I
don't know maybe I can do that I mean
she takes this damn ugly but I couldn't
really figure out a good way to play
here this is not a problem this is this
is clearly okay for me he has to go f3
Antone I can do whatever I can actually
just take and here I'm rather black but
sorry and this I didn't see anything
here the engine wants to go with this
and then f3 and 97 and says it's it's
just slightly better for him
for him well I saw that but I didn't see
really what the big point is if I'm
doing this 95 I ok I'm threatening
Knight f3 check back yeah I am just a
pawn down I mean the engine just gives
you a point five but it really just
feels like being a pawn down ok I did
this and no I'm Lewis am quite clearly
Jim I wasn't sure really about this
Quincy to the engines 495 that's very
strong that's very strong this is the
idea directly going on that weakness no
that's very strong yeah I'm I mean I'm
not okay but I'm kind of still alive
mighty form maybe and now I really am
Alive and jigs this is right and now
immediately 95 yeah I wasn't quite sure
with this but I Charlie I can check I
take out okay I didn't see the check I
didn't see that with a check i'm also
attacking c5 yeah then 95 is clearly
favorable well it's the wrong expression
preferable yeah I have to play it I'm
not sure if I'm really much better or
anything but I have to do it check check
and says this is actually quite nice for
me now not much happens i guess for I
could have played with d3 actually it
probably was better that end game looked
look problematic yeah maybe i'm just
about holding up yeah this is the draw
here pulling him
who he really put a good played a good
game there thanks for watching